hey youtubers is charlie this morning in
my trailer video I asked you all to
submit your doctor who questions so this
video is going to be all about that most
of you just had questions about
Capaldi's catch phrases or old
characters returning thankfully Steven
Moffat has actually said some things
about that quick congrats to Brad Miller
you're this week's giveaway winner it's
an amazon gift card I'll message you on
your channel for details next round of
the giveaway starts whenever I post the
classico video that I've mentioned
before that might end up being Saturday
or sooner if I can get through a few
other videos first remember all you have
to do to enter the Doctor Who giveaways
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the videos so let's answer some
questions on to number one the doctor's
assistant asks what was your first
episode of Doctor Who so the first one
that I can consciously remember planning
to watch on television was the 11th hour
my family was more star wars and lord of
the rings growing up so I didn't
discover Doctor Who until well after the
2005 reboot I think one of the science
fiction blocks I read at the time was
hyping up Matt Smith's debut so I
decided to check it out and fell in love
with it I will say that I think I ended
up liking series 6 more than series 5 or
series 7 just because by the time they
got to series six they were a little
more comfortable and they're closed so
to speak so by that point I was just a
little more connected with the
characters a little more invested in the
story Series seven was a little bit
weird just because of that giant
mid-season break I think it was sometime
after the start of series six that I
started watching Eccleston and tenants
runs there's an infinite amount of
Doctor Who you could watch it till the
end of time and you still wouldn't have
watched it all on to question number 2
keygen bazaine asks when you do videos
for the episodes could you point out the
easter eggs if you see them so I'm
definitely gonna try and catch as many
things as possible but the more doctor
who that you've consumed including the
novel's audio dramas the comics the more
you'll probably end up seeing most of
the stuff that I catch will probably the
really obvious stuff but sometimes
Doctor Who actors make subtle choices in
the scene that might be references to
things that you barely notice so I'll
try to find a way for you guys to
message me during the episodes whatever
you see things that I might miss there's
always gonna be a ton of stuff that you
guys see that I might miss so I'm gonna
try and find an organized way for you
guys to let me know about it during the
episode so that I can include it in the
reviews and give you guys credit on to
question number three crissy Smith asks
do you think that Clara will stick
around or will the changes scare her off
I think that episode one will mostly
take care of Clara getting used to
Capaldi the hurdle that she has to jump
over
is the doctor not being the doctor as
she knows him so their relationship has
to adapt that might actually be why
Moffat chose to include vostra and the
Paternoster gang in the episode just
because they're kind of like a neutral
group of friends foster someone who's
really long lived like the doctor so she
has a much broader perspective on his
life most companions only know one
version of the doctor some do get to see
the new one after the regeneration like
Sarah Jane is definitely gonna be weird
but I do think she's gonna DAP very fast
on to question number 4 Edward asks do
you think the Clara will reference Matt
Smith's doctor a lot or is he done and
gone yes I think that whenever she's
talking to Capaldi she'll still be
thinking Matt Smith in her head
Capaldi's like an abstract idea to her
at this point like seeing your friend in
cosplay I don't know how long she's
gonna keep referring to past events with
the doctor but I think after the first
few episodes she'll start to speak more
in present tense and less about
experiences that she shared with Matt
Smith's doctor I've heard rumors about a
Matt Smith phone call during the episode
if that's the case that could be like
the big hurdle that they jump over when
they start getting on with their lives
there was a clip from episode 2 that's
been posted it's been turned into tumblr
gifs based on the jokes in that i think
that the mat smith references will
largely be limited to the first episode
but you also have to remember that every
time in series 8 that Peter Capaldi runs
into someone that he's seen before but
not for a long time they're gonna have
to get over that first new meeting it's
like meeting the doctor again for the
first time even though you know who he
is on to question number 5 Kaylin cook
asks are there going to be any two
partners this year so yes the finale is
going to be two parter and I can't
remember where but i think i remember
hearing Steven Moffat say that the
stories are supposed to be less
serialized meaning that there's going to
be more one-off episodes it makes sense
that they do that for Capaldi's first
run it's a lot easier for new viewers
people have never watched Doctor Who
before to jump on a series if they don't
have to know a lot of the details of the
earlier episodes they kind of did the
same thing whenever Matt Smith came on
in series five but by the time they made
it to series six the Lake Silencio River
Song plot started ticking up each of the
episodes on to question number six mario
hernandez asks do you think the Capaldi
will use a lot of previous doctors catch
phrases in the episode I've heard that
there's a very signature Tom Baker
catchphrase but I think that he's going
to be doing things from each of the
doctors runs some references will be a
little more obvious than others but the
Polly's doctor is supposed to be closer
to the third and fourth doctor's more
than any of the other doctors that'll
also probably play into a lot of the
Easter eggs and references that get laid
in two episodes so any time you guys see
things from previous doctors you'll be
able to message me and just let me know
you know hate this came from X dr. in X
episode I know a lot of you actually
been asking what I think that Capaldi's
catchphrase is gonna end up being I
actually have no idea but I'd love it if
there were a little bit of Malcolm
Tucker in it I don't think the BBC is
good let them square that much but I
think we'll see some pretty amazing
tumblr edits whatever people start
posting chipsets the episodes like
whenever people put new dialogue on gifs
of Peter Capaldi and Paul McGann from
the thick of it they just make it really
funny and make it a doctor who thing on
to number seven alek Plumlee asks i
watch tenants run but do i need to watch
Matt Smith's run to understand what's
going on so good question no you do not
have to watch it but you should just
because it'll give you a little bit
better context if you don't have time to
watch all of Matt's miss run just watch
series seven be through the Christmas
special if you really really don't have
any time just watch the 50th in the
Christmas special I did post that
beginner's guide with a bunch of
different episodes but the truth is is
that you could literally watch and read
everything and it still wouldn't cover
all the expanded material you really
just have to draw the line somewhere so
you should at least watch the 50th it
was amazing on to question number eight
Michael Jarvis asks do you think that
will see the return of the Omega I don't
think so and here's why it mostly has to
do with the stuff that moffatts bringing
back already are the stuff that we know
that he's bringing back right now of the
things that we do know that he's
bringing back it's all stuff that he's
either written himself or stuff from his
time as showrunner when it comes to
classic ooh i think the things they will
be bringing back are mostly thematic and
visual not so much characters but
character traits in the tone of some of
the previous doctors episodes there's
still a lot that we don't know about
series 8 so it's always possible but i
think that they're trying to introduce
new villains bringing someone like the
omega back would totally overshadow any
new people that they brought on i don't
think they want to steal focus too much
that's part of the reason the master
isn't coming back both that and
scheduling remember Steven Moffat said
that the master was pretty much dead and
gone and John Simm has that new series
intruders that's premiering right after
doctor who episode 1 question number 9
James McQueen asks what's your favorite
artist interior so I always loved new
interior so I always tend to think the
newest is always the best but the last
one that I got really really excite
about was John Hurt's TARDIS he was
introduced as the war doctor you know a
badass so I got so hyped to see what a
TARDIS would look like during the time
war the doctor changed himself to be
more brutal so naturally his console
would fit that personality and function
it ended up looking like a starker
version of nine started like the
precursor to that with the round things
I totally loved it whenever Smith and
tenant were trying to remember the
purpose of the round things and just
couldn't figure it out and on to
question number 10 last one eos asks in
the 50th anniversary Tom Baker told matt
smith he'd be revisiting old faces soon
what do you think that means and are
they going to follow up on it in series
eight so I actually think that it means
two things first that revisiting old
faces is like a literal thing like
they're going to be revisiting the
previous classic doctors and future
anniversaries I think we can all agree
that it was awesome st. Tom Baker show
up and the five ish doctors was totally
fun so he was probably talking about
them coming back in the next special
like literally seeing old faces the
second thing that I think he meant was
revisiting old faces via regenerations
like he was talking about Capaldi even
though we hadn't met him yet Capaldi
talks about his face being familiar and
somehow mysterious like when he looks in
the mirror he recognizes his face as a
face he's seen before but he just can't
place it I think that's going to be one
of the running plots this series finding
out if the doctor is reusing an old face
and if he is why like what's the purpose
in reusing a phase versus picking a new
face so all great questions thank you so
much for submitting them since I'm gonna
have a little bit more time in future
Q&A videos I'll try and include as many
as possible like I'll try and do like 20
or 15 questions instead of doing the
regular 10 and like I said my next video
is going to be the classic who won i'll
try to post that by saturday if not
earlier i have jury duty friday so we'll
see Thursday is like my last day on my
job and then friday after go to jury
duty I know it's totally ridiculous but
in the meantime in case you haven't seen
it click here for my list of essential
episodes before series 8 and click here
to learn about all 12 episode titles we
don't know anything bout the Christmas
special yet but thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you